there's a lot of new people in Las Vegas
I grew up here but for those who don't
know tell me about your your experience
in Las Vegas and you're in the you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wizard depressed we didn't have fresh
foods and vegetables we have the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm tied a mini cutoff go ahead sorry
well I the one of the things that I've
been curious to ask people who've been
in the valley for a long time about
especially those like yourself have been
involved in civil rights activities and
so forth is how art can you describe the
frustration I think is an understatement
but I'll just use that word frustration
that this is happening now that the not
that the protests are happening but that
the reason for the protests still exists
aha what goes through your mind when you
or if you read or see what is taking
place not only in Las Vegas but around
the country
[Music]
the real story
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
children
[Music]
[Music]
couple of days but who is George
[Music]
[Music]
no I understand I mean it's I mean I can
I don't under how to say this but I can
appreciate where the pain and the
frustration comes from but I guess what
I'm trying to see if there's a way to do
is is not compare but sort of see if
there's a line to draw or some sort of a
correlation or something between the
marches you would talk about and I
realize that the may be the subject
matter in some cases a little different
it's still it's justice at the core but
is there a are you disappointed that
the that marching is still necessary
that is from between the 19 let's just
say 60s until now it's still people
still have to go into the streets for
two for justice for equality for a
social justice as someone who's been
involved in civil rights for as long as
you have happening
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my last question is a short question but
I think it probably has a long answer
what needs to happen to make equality to
make it right I don't mean to be so
simplistic about it because I know it's
it's a it's a it's unbelievably
important but what what what can come
from this
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
are you encouraged or you just yes and I
kind of ask you this a little bit before
but when you see the protests and they
see the peaceful protest and then
unfortunately there's some people that
are you know that kind of get in the way
of that but when you see these images on
the screen you see the marching on the
strip you you know in New York and all
over the place I kind of asked you this
already I realized that but what do you
think is you're watching these people
marching down the street and you're
seeing these confrontations in some
cases you're seeing these people taking
action
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the I will say though the you know
sometimes if you talk to certain folks
they will say and I'm not saying
vandalism but they will say that
large-scale like you know blocking the
whole strip that level of guests
disobedience for lack of a better word
you know you I guess some might suggest
that you can't be nice anymore if you
really want change you gotta take the
fight to another level
[Music]
[Laughter]
I appreciate your time apologize for
calling you out of the blue my last
question my last question is can you
just say and spell your name in case
someone else listens to this later